Paint, in some form, has existed since prehistoric
times.
Some of the earliest forms of paint came from
mixing together dirt, ash, and organic materials
with animal blood and oil.
While the practice of painting the exterior
of various structures has been around for
some unclear amount of time since, not everyone
was on board with this in relatively recent
times.
For instance, certain early American settlers
declared the act of painting the outside of
houses a sign of immodesty, wealth and vanity.
Depending on how puritanical a community was,
painting a house might have even landed a
person in legal trouble.
For farmers and their barns in certain regions,
this same mentality applied.
A painted barn was a sign of extravagance
and since the main function of paint at the
time was merely to add color to a structure
or room, farmers didn’t see much point in
spending money to make their barns pretty.
So how did they preserve the wood of their
buildings without proper sealants?
Prior to the 19th century, the preservative
philosophy many farmers believed in was, “The
right wood in the right place needed no paint.”
Part of the process of deciding on a location
to build a barn was based on a farmer’s
careful assessment of the wind, sun, and water
exposure the wood exterior would endure through
the years.
This tried and true method, combined with
plentiful, naturally weather resistance heartwood,
made many barns quite durable despite their
exteriors remaining au naturel.
As years passed, however, the practice of
weather assessment fell to the wayside, with
farmers dabbling in more convenient and longer
lasting solutions to protect their barns from
the elements.
Various homemade concoctions towards this
end were made, with a popular base in these
being linseed oil.
To strengthen the oil and help it dry and
harden quickly, it soon became common to mix
it with milk and lime or turpentine, creating
something of a burnt-orange color weather
treating paint.
iron-oxideWhile this mixture sealed wood from
moisture somewhat, it did not inhibit the
growth of mold and moss that plagued wooden
structures.
For the solution to this, iron oxide, otherwise
known as rust, was also added to the homemade
paint.
Iron oxide could be found in abundance in
the soil on farms in the eastern United States,
among other places, which made it literally
dirt-cheap and easy to obtain.
Depending on the exact soil composition and
amount of iron oxide used for a particular
homemade batch of the paint, it would take
on anywhere from the aforementioned burnt-orange
color to dark red-brown.
When such paint became cheaply available via
mass production in the late 1800s, farmers
often stuck with the color red because, thanks
to the abundance of iron oxide, red paint
was still generally the cheapest paint on
the shelf (although this is certainly not
the case today).
As for why barns are still often painted red
(albeit generally much brighter reds than
the classic red-brown) despite no real inherent
cost savings anymore, this is just down to
tradition.
The word “barn” originated from the Old
English words “bere” and “aern.”
“Bere” means barley or grain and “aern”
describes a storage place, so barn essentially
mean a storage place
for grain.